bienvenidos veamos el problema número 92
en cierta tienda de muebles mariana
recibe un salario de 240 más del 5 por
ciento del total de las ventas que están
por encima de los 800 a la semana si
mariana recibe un total de 450 a la
semana cuánto fue lo que vendió en esa
semana vamos a notar los datos nos dicen
que mariana recibe un sueldo semanal de
240 más el 5%
de lo que sea que se recibió que fue
mayor a 800 y nos dicen
ok nos están diciendo que ganó 450 esta
semana 450 y esto le vamos a quitar el
sueldo que gana que es de 240 menos 240
los restamos y nos queda 210 210
así que 210 es el 5% de que número 210
210 es el 5%
5 % de que número x es nuestra incógnita
entonces si despejamos de aquí xx va a
ser igual a 210 entre punto 05.05
hagamos esta división
/
punto 05 vamos a mover este punto
decimal 2 lugares aquí lo vamos a mover
1 2
este lo movemos también dos lugares aquí
me va a quedar mi punto y aquí me va a
quedar mi punto para hacer esta división
más fácil ok vamos a multiplicar esto
por 4 5 por 4 20 20 menos 21 nos queda 1
bajamos un cero
5 x 2 10 aquí queda 0 bueno queda un 10
lo resto aquí queda 0 así que nos queda
que son 4 mil 200 pero éstas nos fueron
las ventas totales sólo que lo que
estuvo por arriba de 800 así que las
ventas totales son 4200 4200 que es
nuestra x más los 800
y nos queda que es igual a 5 mil 5000
que es nuestra opción
siguiente problema problema número 93
nos da la lista 1 que es 36 819 y la
lista 2 que es x 36 8 y 19 si la mediana
de los números de la lista 1 es igual a
la mediana de la lista 2 cuál es el
valor de x vamos a encontrar primero la
mediana de la lista 1 bueno esta mediana
se va a encontrar como tenemos números
pares se va a encontrar en el promedio
de estos dos números el promedio de 6 y
8 6 + 8 son 14 14 entre 27 la mediana de
la lista 1 es 7
la mediana es 7
ok y nos dicen entonces que esta mediana
de 7 también tiene que ser la misma
mediana de esta lista número 2 donde
tendremos que colocar x para tener la
misma mediana
bueno ya que x puede estar en cualquier
posición de acá pues vemos que aquí nos
falta o podemos poner justamente un 7 de
manera que la lista 2 nos quede como 36
y 19
y ahora sí con esta distribución nuestra
mediana sería esta y es 7 que es la
misma que la lista 1 esta va a ser
nuestra opción b
opción b
veamos el problema número 94
en cierta ciudad el 60% de los votantes
registrados son demócratas y el resto
son republicanos en la elección para
gobernador el 70% de los votantes que
son demócratas y el 20% de los votantes
republicanos van a votar por el
candidato a cuál es el porcentaje de los
votantes registrados que votarán por el
candidato a
de hecho aquí es que votarán ok nos
dicen entonces que los votantes
demócratas es el 60% de todos los
votantes puntos 6 debe que el esta vez
de votantes
los republicanos pues son el resto es
decir el 40 por ciento de todos los
votantes nos dicen que el 75% de los
demócratas
o de los votantes que son demócratas 75%
de de más el 20% de ere 0.2 de r van a
votar por el candidato a vamos a
sustituir estos de si estás eres aquí de
manera que nos queda 0.75 por de que es
puntos seis por b punto 6
por vez más puntos dos por r
3.4 por b
0.4 por d
y vamos a desarrollar esto punto 75 por
punto 6
es igual 6 por 5 30 llevo 36 742 más 345
y tengo unos 23 lugares a la derecha del
punto decimal por lo que el punto
decimal aquí lo recorro tres lugares
esto es puntos dos por punto 4 es igual
a punto 8.08 por los dos lugares
decimales que tenemos aquí punto 0 8
y la suma de estos dos nos dan punto 53
me faltó poner aquí la ve de votantes
porque es la multiplicación por el total
de los votantes registrados
punto 5.45 por be más punto 8 por veces
igual a punto 53 de los votantes
registrados así que los que van a votar
por el candidato a están ubicados en la
opción b
muy bien último problema de este vídeo
problema número 95 cierto plan de retiro
de una empresa tiene una regla de 70 que
le permite al empleado retirarse cuando
cumpla a la edad del empleado más en el
tiempo que ha trabajado en la empresa la
suma de estos dos sea mayor o igual a 70
en qué año podría una empleada
contratada en 1986 teniendo 32 años de
edad retirarse de la empresa bajo esta
regla nos dicen la regla es a la edad
del empleado al ser contratado más en el
tiempo que es empleado trabajo en esa
empresa la suma debe ser mayor o igual a
ok para saber la edad de la mujer lo
puedo expresar como
- 1986 el año en que se contrato
más 32 que es la edad que ya tiene así
que esto es a la edad de la mujer todo
esto de acá es a qué va a ser
el tiempo que trabajó en la empresa el
tiempo que trabajó en la empresa va a
ser el año de mi interés menos pues el
año de 1986 que fue cuando se contrató
la diferencia de estos años tengo que
voy a sumar a más
esto lo voy a sumar así que me queda
esto es igual a 2
- 2 por 1986 más 32 32 a ese es un 9
que mi pluma está algo lento ustedes
disculpen la lentitud con la que escribo
pero bueno esto debe ser mayor o igual a
vamos a dividir todo entre 2 me va a
quedar que si esto lo divide entre 2 -
1986 por 2 entre 2 pues me queda 1986
32 entre 26 16
mayor o igual que 35 kg va a ser mayor o
igual a 35 aquí estoy
despejando y 35 más 1986
- 16 menos 16 esto es igual a 1970 35
esto es
igual a 2005
5 esta persona se podría retirar a
partir del año 2005 que es mi opción c y
con esto terminamos este problema y nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo